hoy 156 millones de brasileños están
llamados a las urnas para escoger al
nuevo presidente el ex presidente Luis y
nace Luna da Silva está en la delantera
en los sondeos con el 54% de intención
de Voto Yair bolsonaro dijo en el último
debate que va a aceptar democráticamente
el resultado sin embargo en las filas de
la oposición hay temor de que en caso de
derrota de bolsonaro puede haber
disturbios en las calles
estoy con miedo porque nunca he creído
en bolsonaro y creo que no va a cumplir
su palabra por eso estamos con recelo de
estar en la calle
yo prefiero evitar hoy pisar la calle
para prevenir
No creo que esta noche haya confusión en
las calles Estos son rumores en realidad
Yo hoy voy a votar a bolsonaro y no voy
a causar confusión si él pierde si
bolsonaro pierde vamos a esperar que el
próximo presidente haga un buen trabajo
como dice que va a hacer
No no
sinceramente
no tengo miedo de esta confusión
sinceramente si él dijo que va a aceptar
el resultado lo va a hacer pero el ser
humano es imprevisible todos somos
diferentes Entonces bolsonaro no puede
responder por nosotros
estamos en el mismo colegio electoral
donde estuvimos Hace cuatro semanas
durante la primera vuelta lo que notamos
hoy es que está más vacío en la primera
vuelta hubo un 21% de abstención es
decir 32 millones de brasileños no
fueron a votar la ciencia política
indica que la segunda vuelta la
obtención suele subir Hoy por la noche
sabremos Quién es el nuevo presidente de
Brasil y si efectivamente hubo más
abstención